Another type synchronization that we often need in
programs, is called barrier synchronization. This often occurs when
there is a parallel section where several threads are
doing something independent of each other, for example each
thread is adding up the numbers in its
own part of a shared array. Eventually, we want
to know the total sum. So what needs to
happen is we need to make sure that everybody
has finished their own adding up, and that's
what the barrier is. And only then somebody, for
example, thread 0, can actually form the total
sum and, for example, print it out. We don't
want it to print the sum before we
know that everybody's contributions to the sum are complete.
Another thing that can happen is that we are
computing the sum in this parallel way, and then
all of the threads need to use this sum. So
again, all of them need to wait for the sum
to be certainly done. And only then can they proceed
to actually use the sum. If thread 0 starts using the
sum before making sure that other threads are done computing
the sum, then what happens is we are using the sum
that may not include all of the numbers that are
in the array. Same for any other thread. So the barrier
pretty much is a global wait that ensures that all threads have entered the
barrier before any of them can proceed
past the barrier. So the barrier synchronization ensures
that all threads that need to arrive to the barrier have arrived before any
can leave the barrier. A barrier implementation
can have two variables. A counter that counts
how many threads have arrived and the flag that gets
set when the counter finally reaches N. So what each
tread arriving to the barrier needs to do is increment
the counter, check if the counter is equal to the
number of threads that need to arrive. If it is
equal, set the flag. If it's not equal, that means
we are not the last arriving thread. Then we spin,
waiting on the flag to finally become set. Of course,
things are not as simple.